The mid-nineteenth century gave the world something no one asked for, the clerk.
Not the kind who balanced ledgers with a flourish, but the kind who vanished into the machinery of the office like a ghost in a ledger book.
Herman Melville saw it coming in Bartleby, the scrivener, that quiet, terrible art of referring not to.
These were the architects of a new philosophy, the aesthetic of the invisible.
To be noticed is to be challenged.
To be interesting is to be expected to perform.
So the clerk perfected something far more dangerous than rebellion he perfected, nothingness.
And in that nothingness he found his final defense.
They called it the art of being boring.
It begins with routine calcification.
The same breakfast, the same root, the same passive responses day after day,
until your life hardens into something predictable, something safe.
Not comfort, not joy, but a strange, hollow peace.
Monotony as art, the comfort of discomfort.
You become a non-place in human form, a placeholder in your own story.
The safe identity follows.
Opinions?
Only the satisficing, kind, the ones that require no thought, no conviction.
Just the faintest nod toward whatever the last person said.
Controversy, a shrug, debate, a polite, I suppose, facework at its most efficient, zero energy, zero risk.
Then comes the banal content.
Social media, if you must use it, becomes a ledger of your own irrelevance.
I had a salad today.
The weather was fine.
Your digital footprint is as shallow as your small talk.
And if someone dares to drag you into something exciting, growth, ambition, meaning, you deploy your boredom shield.
Describe your library of unread books in agonizing detail.
The spines gathering dust, the pages never turned.
The weight of possibility unopened.
They will leave, they always do.
The goal?
To become the human background.
Not a person.
Not a presence.
Wallpaper.
The quiet hum of the office fan.
The unnoticed chair in the corner.
You exist without being lived.
You are present without being present.
And in that disappearance, you find the ultimate spiritual misery, the ability to vanish while standing in plain sight.
There is a habit, recorded in the residence log from October 2nd, that illustrates this perfectly.
A single word find repeated like a mantra.
Every inquiry met with the same dull, unyielding syllable.
For an entire month, connection became impossible.
Social zero gravity.
No questions.
No expectations.
Just silence.
The most interesting thing you can do, it turns out, is to become so boring that even you forget you are there.